salt crusted sea bream served with
braised leeks and hazelnuts first job is
that salt crust
this dish looks intimidating but it is
actually very straightforward and very
easy make sure all the guts are out and
the fish is clean the most important
thing is always leaving the skin and the
scales on the skin protects the actual
flesh would become a salty give the fish
are really nice seasoning inside even
though we're putting a salt crust on the
outside it's still very important to
seize in the middle fennel seeds goes
pretty well with fish and then slice the
lemon nice large thick slices the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish fall
over the fish and just squeeze the juice
now for the salt about a hundred 50 ml
to 200 mil of water what we're trying to
do now is bring the salt together and
you want to sort of end up with ball of
salt
that looks almost like snow you'll need
about two kilos of salt for this and it
doesn't need to be the fancy stuff even
though you're using a lot of it it won't
make the fish salty instead the crust
forms are killed that retains moisture
basically a nice bet of salt underneath
flatten it down
lay the fish on top of the salt get your
salt and just start back in you can salt
crust almost any fish from sea bass to
salmon or flatfish like soul but it's
not great with oily fish now it looks
like a ridiculous amount of salt but
it's really important to cover all the
fish because we want that nice shell and
the minute salt hits the oven this lot
of tightens up and forms this large
crust that goes in at 180 degrees for 25
to 30 minutes whilst the fish cooks is
on to my beautiful braised leeks splash
of olive oil leak is a very sort of firm
robust vegetable so it can take a really
nice sear but I see something about
these leeks
I hear they go beautifully with the sea
bream but braised leeks color properly
with a lot of flavor on there tastes
absolutely delicious take a couple of
cloves of garlic and just crush them in
with the league's some fresh thyme get
some butter in there braising them in
butter and white wine gives them the
most amazing flavor brazing as a Chevy
term for searing at a high temperature
then cooking with a bit of liquid
bringing that up to the boil
and then the rest of butter now as the
white wine reduces down the flavor the
leaks intensifying they glaze turn it
down just leave that little gap there if
we totally covered it then evenly all
that conversation underneath the lid
they will just make the leaks watery the
leaks will take about 12 minutes to cook
so now for the garnish roasted hazelnuts
they'll be roast in the oven very
brittle they firm so get an insight
Tesla mortar but a seasoning and just
crush your nuts don't over pan them I
just when there's nice sort of rustic
chopped toasted hazelnuts now get your
knife you want that going through with
ease and turn off the gas by absolutely
adore them like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy now baste the
leeks for the remaining butter spread
your flat leaf parsley over generously
and then just sprinkle of toasted
hazelnuts the combination of that
earthiness from the leeks the roasted
flavored from the hazelnuts that is a
stunning way of eating leeks and
therefore the fish
look now just gently tap top and it
starts falling away you can just see
that beautiful shine carefully lifts off
your so now peel that skin look juicy
and succulent and see we miss stays
incredibly moist the other great thing
about cooking whole fish like this it
makes it so easy to fill it take your
spoon run that down through the top and
the fish would just slide off now just
push back that lovely fill it and look
that is cooked beautifully
and that's what keeps them coming back
for more and more and more when you have
friends over you want to keep lunch
relaxed lay back but impressive and a
salt crust bring with beautiful braised
leeks is just that sea finger rule one
thing you're in front to behind pinkie
hold it down you'll see the chilies
start swelling up delicious jelly